he has enough problem being being
vilified himself as a racist because he
uses and his scripts that much or puts
those kinds of words in a character's
mouth I get tired of Defending Quentin
because I think he has a right to to
write what he writes when you start
criticizing Quentin for being a racist
or whatever then you have to wonder why
he writes roles for me that are
intelligent that has the most dignity
and respect and kind of runs things and
is is
is not a fool of any sort and if you're
going to characterize or criticize his
dialogue then we need to go back through
the dialogue and Straight Out of Compton
or even Chiraq or wherever else and go
well if you're not gonna censor that
then you can't censor this and for him
the right characters like that for me
would be impossible for a racist to do